and there you can see Joe Biden uh with
uh his partner uh Jill uh looking at the
coffin of PR of uh Queen Elizabeth
we've seen a number of world leaders
paying their respects today including
King Felipe of Spain the Swedish
King as well the Swedish prime minister
and and seeing Joe Biden there crossing
himself
alongside his wife Jill powerful images
inside Westminster Hall and of course he
will be seen by those who have cued many
many hours to come past and see the
queen as well won't he
we're not getting anything the coffin
has been won not only of paying tribute
and respect to Queen Elizabeth uh
herself but also there's been so many
moments where individuals like Joe Biden
as you can see on the screen there uh
with his wife Jill uh being present and
I think what has made this moment so
special for the thousands of people
who've passed through Westminster Hall
the building that you can see in front
of you is that not only has there been
the coffin but at some points you have
seen King Charles at some point uh his
sons at some point members of the
cabinet all paying their respects and
now today you have the foreign
dignitaries coming and filing and paying
their respects not necessarily walking
directly past the coffin but instead
going up to that viewing platform a
little bit elevated so they can get a
special view of what's going on on the
podium in front of them